depuis dimanche on parle beaucoup du
faible taux de participation aux
élections municipales
mais est-ce qu'on est les seuls ici est
ce que ça se passe ailleurs dans le
reste du canada par exemple ou encore
aux états unis vient de vivre
pour cette élection dans la ville de
québec plus de 50% des gens qui sont
allés voter
alors qu'à montréal ces 42 pour ça ceux
qui rient spécialistes nous disent c'est
que quand on a une communauté plus petit
que les villes se trouve par exemple
dans des milieux ruraux il ya plus de
chances que les gens aillent voter parce
qu'ils savent que leur vote doivent
faire l'addition
c'est d'ailleurs probablement ce qui
explique que dans certaines villes au
québec on a de grands taux de
participation par exemple grande vallée
en gaspésie 83% et rivière saint jean
sur la côte-nord 90 pour ça on dit tout
à l'heure que 42% des électeurs se sont
présentés dans les bureaux de vote à
montréal
regardez ce que ça donne et dans
certaines grandes villes canadiennes
lors de leurs derniers scrutins à eux
calgary 58 % de taux de participation
toronto 55 pour cent vingt couverts 43%
ottawa 40% puis à moncton trente trois
portes aux états unis maintenant
new york 26 % des électeurs inscrits
sont allés voter en 2013
austin au texas 5 % las vegas 8% et
dallas 6% alors je pense qu'on peut en
conclure que ce n'est pas une réalité
qui est seulement québécoise si vous
voulez qu'on vérifie quelque chose
écrivent ils